scp 682 versus scp-3207  no weapon the foundation has ever  created has been able to kill  scp-682 so maybe a crazy anomalous  energy cannon created by leonardo da  vinci and marco saul will get the job  done the tissue test went well as the  energy cannon was able to completely  vaporize the scp-682 flesh with a single  blast with this promising result they  went on to the full test 3207 appeared  to completely annihilate scp-682 with a  few well-aimed blasts leading to a great  deal of relief among the attending  researchers for a few hours at least  several nasty little creatures  regenerated from the scattered tissue of  scp-682  when these creatures breached  containment they fused back into scp-682  because of course they did